[Musica]
allora da qua non vedo niente era già
vedo tutto nero però ho una spia in sala
che mi ha detto che oggi qui tra il
pubblico ci sono persone della mia
generazione ci sono persone sicuramente
della generazione successiva e forse
alcune della generazione precedente e
quindi lasciate che mi presenti nel modo
forse più comprensibile per tutti io mi
chiamo camilla
forse alcuni di voi mi conoscono come
camilo che è quella che vedete alle mie
spalle e una lista delle cose che mi
mettevano ansia quando andavo al liceo i
primi nel 2000 abbiamo una versione di
greco il greco non abbiamo mai avuto un
grande rapporto l'ho capito il giorno in
cui traducendo la morte di cleopatra
ho cercato sul vocabolario ahahah spisa
speed of che in greco può voler dire sia
affair pente sia scudo vi tralascio
l'imbarazzo delle mie compagne quando la
macchina del caffè dopo la versione che
di loro se avevano già sentito di questa
bizzarra versione del mito in cui
cleopatra moriva per mano di uno scudo
poi abbiamo litigare con gli amici vabbè
grande classico dell'adolescenza i dubbi
sulle prime esperienze sessuali perché
quella è l'età e poi la domanda che si
pone ogni studente
dopo il liceo quindi se con sé come
continuare a studiare oppure andare a
lavorare
questa invece è una slide delle cose che
mi metterebbero ansia se al liceo ci
andassi oggi nel 2019
abbiamo sempre la versione di greco
perché è comunque non saprei tradurre
neanche nel 2009 la terra che a causa
dell'inquinamento ci dà il benservito
poi c'era il caos democratico ma non
sapevamo come disegnato e quindi abbiamo
detto li chiamo dalla slide e poi c'è la
mia autore auto rappresentazione sui
social consapevole del fatto che pochi
minuti prima sullo stesso social si sono
auto rappresentate anche gigi hadid e
kendall jenner che per mio padre in sala
traduco essere due delle modelle più
influenti e tuttora in circolazione
quindi a quello che vorrei fare oggi è
partire un po della mia esperienza
perché io sui social ci lavoro per
cercare di rispondere a la domanda che
forse è croce e delizia di noi
als e cioè capire come proprio con
l'avvento dei social network sia
cambiato non solo quello che raccontiamo
il modo in cui lo facciamo ma anche la
nozione stessa di realtà dei fatti e le
conseguenze che questo cambiamento ha
avuto nella nostra quotidianità
quindi forse la domanda più giusta da
porsi che non è questa slide ma ce ne
dovrebbe essere un'altra sono in
disordine va beh ve la dico io la
domanda ci dovremmo volere oggi un bacio
alla regia è quello che vediamo sui
social è vero quello che vediamo su
instagram è vero
ovviamente non parlerò nei di fake news
né di comunicazione politica perché non
mi sento la persona più competente per
farlo in una casa sono partita proprio
dalle mie ansie del liceo della mia
esperienza mi ricordo che quando ero ero
adolescente tutto quel fiume in piena di
crisi emotive il mio senso di
inadeguatezza la tristezza per quelle
relazioni che speravo durassero per
sempre e poi sono finite per fortuna
aggiungo oggi confluivano tutte o nella
blogosfera
mi ricordo all'epoca c'era myspace
oppure nelle famigerate intestazioni dei
messeni messenger
molti di voi si ricorderanno
raccoglievano delle citazioni
meravigliose jim morrison baudelaire poi
dipendeva un po dalle a reference
personali di ciascuno e anche la musica
mi ricordo che rispecchiava le nostre
pretese di profondità
ora non voglio dire che all'epoca non ci
fosse già una componente di moda nella
narrazione di sé un amico psicologo mi
ha detto che l'adolescenza è proprio
quel momento in cui inizi a voler
piacere alle altre persone
non importa che questo accada sui social
network o nella vita reale ma è proprio
il momento in cui il tuo obiettivo
diventa quello di farsi accettare dagli
altri non so se i liceali gli
adolescenti di oggi
in concreto siano più o meno felici di
quanto non lo ero io quello che so è che
hanno imparato a mostrarsi felici o
quantomeno hanno capito che essere
percepiti come tali come felici in un
certo senso aumenta la loro invidia
bilità sociale è questo
sta ma un loro comprensibilissimo e
condivisibilissimo bisogno di
accettazione era appunto quello che
dicevamo prima quindi la domanda che non
è comparsa ma che vi ripropongo io è
quello che vediamo che questi giovani
rappresentano sui loro social
corrisponde alla realtà per cercare di
trovare una risposta ho letto bauman non
so se avete mai provato poi non lo
rifarò mai più è bastata complesso
quello che posso dire di aver capito è
che nel teorizzare che liquefarsi della
società
bauman ci dice che a un certo momento in
un certo momento il nostro concetto di
tempo è come colato ogni istante è
diventato infinitamente gravido di
scelte possibili e delle loro
conseguenze
ne segue che qualsiasi decisione noi
prendiamo sarà sempre potenzialmente un
po sbagliata
questo perché ne avremmo potute prendere
infinite altre e ci sarebbero state
altrettante conseguenze
contemporaneamente a questo liquefarsi
del concetto di tempo bauman dice che
sono collassate tutte quelle
sovrastrutture come la società o la
politica che in un certo senso potevano
guidare l'individuo nelle sue scelte e
questo ha portato una radicalizzazione
di ogni conseguenza le scelte che prendo
sono mie mi è soltanto così come le
responsabilità che da queste che da
queste scelte derivano diciamo come
dicevamo prima cioè vorrei ricollegarmi
a quello che ho detto prima ovvero che
questo cambiamento nella narrazione dei
fatti è avvenuto non a causa dei social
network ma è venuto in contemporanea
prima e dopo l'avvento dei social
network però quello che senz'altro i
social hanno aggiunto questa condizione
preesistente e l'impossibilità di
dimenticarsene in ogni momento e quindi
ecco che su una sola schermata e questa
è giusta io ho davanti quanta fortuna in
più in amore ha avuto una persona con i
capelli biondi che metratura avrebbe
casa mia
se avessi fatto la bocconi al posto
della statale dove andrei andrà in
vacanza se avesse avuto un'altra
compagnia di amici e non quella che ho
avuto
quindi l'aspetto ansiogeno se vogliamo
dei social network è proprio questo ti
ti ti pone davanti una realtà ovvero ti
pone davanti quello che saresti potuto
essere se solo non fosse quello che sei
se solo non avessi preso le decisioni
che hai preso ora sicuramente un mini
speaker o in un discorso che è quello
sull'identità cui non sono arrivati a
capo il milioni di filosofia
figurati se ci riesco io che traduco
scudo con serpente quindi lasciamo
perdere però quello che volevo fare con
voi oggi a commentare una citazione che
mi è sempre piaciuta molto abbiamo
sempre va ma quello di prima che però
riprende una riflessione di albert camus
e baumann ci dice che quando guardiamo
alla nostra condizione ci percepiamo
sempre come frammentari come incompiuti
viviamo in un costante senso di
incompiutezza
quando invece guardiamo le esistenze
delle altre persone queste ci appaiono
come estremamente coerenti come
estremamente unitarie
ma questa non è la realtà questa è
un'illusione ottica
quella è la domanda che dopo previa è
un'eccezione ottica un'illusione data
dalla distanza che ci separa da queste
persone distanza intesa proprio come
inadeguatezza della conoscenza che si
offusca i dettagli nella realtà delle
altre persone e queste l'uso in ottica
ce le fa vedere come delle vere e
proprie opere d'arte e quindi il nostro
intento diventa quello di rappresentarci
anche noi in modo unitario affinché gli
altri percepiscano la nostra vita come
un'opera d'arte e rappresentarsi mode
unitario in realtà è sempre esistito
forse se qualcuno di voi ha fatto il suo
classico come me se lo ricorderà ma ai
tempi mentre le fly ed oggi non ci sono
spetta a vela cerco perché eccola qua
fin dall'antichità ii e le statue gli
epiteti formulari raccontavano quello
che era il ruolo pubblico della persona
infatti di marco aurelio
ci ricordiamo che era un condottiero non
c'è mai interessato sapere qual era il
suo cibo preferito e come condottiero
veniva rappresentato un uomo a cavallo e
così tanti uomini d'armi prima e dopo di
lui
poi c'è stata una sovrapposizione fra il
ruolo pubblico e ruolo privato e abbiamo
capito che cosa succede quando ad essere
mostrata e la realtà privata di una
persona con tutte le sue mutevolezza a
questo punto il mondo diventa una messa
in scena
noi conosciamo la realtà attraverso la
finzione e in forma di finzione
diventiamo come don chisciotte in un
certo senso siamo gli autori della
nostra auto fiction
potremmo dire e quindi torno alla
domanda che ci siamo fatti all'inizio
ovvero se quella che noi mostriamo è la
nostra rappresentazione della realtà
possiamo credere che questa sco in c.da
con la realtà reale
la risposta che ho provato a darmi un po
per la piccola esperienza che ho avuto
nel mondo del lavoro e che un po quello
che vediamo è vero un po è finto un po
forse non è la domanda giusta da porsi
relativamente a un social network che ti
permette di comparire con le orecchie da
coniglio la voce di paperino e produrre
polvere di stelle quando battere ciglia
però quello che penso sia importante al
netto del fatto che i contenuti sui
social su instagram esistano a
prescindere dal loro valore è che è
importante sfruttare questa possibilità
per creare un confronto e un dialogo
positivo con la community
non so se sicuramente ve lo ricorderete
ma internet
un tempo era un posto molto diverso
internet era costituito da tante
community e si partecipava si accedeva
queste community con degli avatar
o quantomeno delle identità alternative
da allora le cose sono molto cambiate
c'è stato un grosso cambiamento che
l'autore di questo cambiamento è stato
proprio mark zuckenberg che io
affettuosamente chiamo marco ecco marco
quando ha introdotto il suo progetto è
stato molto chiaro ha detto su facebook
i profili non devono essere fake
e infatti noi dal 2004 non ci aspettiamo
più che internet offra un'alternativa
alla realtà anzi ci aspettiamo che
internet la documenti
e la rispecchi quello senz'altro
virtuale e reale
a questo punto hanno iniziato a
convergere e questa convergenza è stata
alimentata dal bisogno di comunicare di
ciascuno di noi io stessa camilla quando
sono online lascio delle tracce che
rispondono a questa mia esigenza di
comunicare con gli altri non sempre
questa comunicazione va a buon fine o
perlomeno non sempre ricevo la risposta
che speravo di ricevere questo è un
video che ho registrato ormai diverso
tempo fa sul cyberbullismo
questo perché spesso il nostro al nostro
bisogno di di comunicazione riceviamo
una risposta estremamente narcisistica
quindi abbiamo insulti abbiamo commenti
completamente avulsi dal contesto
io stessa che sui social ci lavoro sono
molto spaventata spesso ne pensare a
come sarebbe stata oggi la mia vita se
io avessi passato la mia adolescenza in
stretto contatto con con i social
network perché sappiamo tutti
insomma le conseguenze che i social
network hanno avuto sulla salute mentale
degli adolescenti
pensate che il 48 per cento degli
studenti si dichiara ansioso depresso
triste proprio a causa di questo
spasmodico bisogno che sia di creare dei
contenuti piacevoli intesi proprio come
valevoli di un mi piace e non entrerò
nel nel grande discorso di come i social
network abbiano cambiato la percezione
del corpo essere costantemente di fronte
a dei corpi perfetti ha creato delle
aspettative enormi soprattutto nelle
donne
esiste una condizione mentale che si
chiama snap chat di smorfia che porta le
persone a volersi sottoporre ad
interventi chirurgici per assomigliare
alla versione migliorata di se stessi
che vedono con le applicazioni con con i
filtri che proprio social network ci
permettono di inserire
ora a fare da contraltare sicuramente a
questa enorme mole di problemi che
indubbiamente i social si sono portati
dietro c'è anche da dire che internet
ormai è diventata una possibilità di
comunicazione
direi imprescindibile e spesso mi
chiedono come ho iniziato la mia
carriera tanto dico grazie per carriera
perché insomma tuttora mi sembra ancora
un po strano però poi dico sempre che
forse tutto è successo perché non sapevo
fare niente meglio degli altri e questo
ha caratterizzato la mia comunicazione
in realtà fin dall'inizio ho sempre
pensato che per me la vicinanza con
l'utenza fosse imprescindibile come
saprete con l'avvento dei social network
noi siamo diventati tutti prosumer siamo
contemporaneamente sia creatori che i
consumatori di contenuti e io spesso
quando navigo su internet sono
disorientata perché la la mole di
contenuti è infinita e quindi scelgo di
di seguire le persone della cui funzione
di curatore io mi fido una buona
funzione curatela è quella che ti offre
un punto di vista sul mondo quello che
giornalisticamente potrebbe essere
definito un angolo di realtà quindi
quella che pone l'accento su determinati
elementi a discapito di altri con la
risultante che quello che facciamo
vedere agli altri quello che offriamo è
il risultato di una scelta ben precisa
che facciamo noi scegliamo quanta e
quale realtà decidiamo di condividere
quelle altre persone e del risultato
anche di quanta compassione proprio in
senso etimologico riusciamo a provare
per noi stessi
nell'accettare ogni tanto di essere
anche tristi di essere anche malinconici
e di condividerlo a cuor leggero
in un certo senso ora
sui social si parla già di temi come la
depressione come l'attraversamento di
momenti critici però quello che succede
che lo si fa sempre a posteriori
quindi si passa un momento difficile si
aspetta che questo finisca
e dopo si racconta di aver attraversato
questa difficoltà sono d'accordo nel
senso
in parte ci sono senz'altro dei momenti
che necessitano di solitudine di
silenzio proprio per la delicatezza che
li contraddistingue però la verità è che
ogni tanto entro sui social network e mi
chiedo se sono l'unica ad essere ogni
tanto un po triste a dire ma forse non è
stata una gran giornata forse le cose
non sono andate esattamente come come
speravo andassero e quindi il messaggio
che vorrei lasciarvi oggi è quello che
cerco di fare tutti i giorni o sui
social network è proprio questo cercare
di ampliare il vocabolario cercare di
aumentare proprio lo spettro del del
dicibile del raccontabile per provare a
creare una comunicazione che sia la più
profonda è la più veritiera possibile
con l'utenza che linguaggio utilizziamo
però per questa mission potremmo dire un
consiglio ce l'ho da calvino
abbiamo la giusta un consiglio ce l'ho
da calvino nelle sue lezioni americane
in particolare nella lezione sulla
leggerezza calvino ci dice che esiste
una leggerezza nella pensosità così come
tutti sappiamo che esiste una frivole
una leggerezza nella frivolezza ed è
proprio la leggerezza pensosa che può
fare apparire la frivolezza come pesante
e opaca quindi forse è proprio questo il
vero a cui dobbiamo puntare su instagram
dobbiamo proprio cercare un nuovo codice
un nuovo linguaggio che sia in grado di
rappresentarci con clemenza che sia in
grado di coinvolgere anche le nostre
debolezze e mostrare i nostri difetti
vorrei concludere il mio intervento di
oggi con con kurt vonnegut che è uno è
il padre di uno degli aforismi più
abusati sui social network per intendere
per intenderci lui era quello che diceva
quando siete felici fateci caso
ecco io dico fateci caso anche quando
non si
siete felici quando quando siete tristi
quando siete malinconici quando le cose
non sono andate come speravate
fateci caso e postatelo postatelo a cuor
leggero in un certo senso perché dovrete
essere consapevoli che dall'altra parte
ci siamo noi che sappiamo come ci si
sente grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]